tourism is one of the industries it's
been worst hit by the corona virus
pandemic
it's estimated that global travel will
fall by 30 to up to 30 percent this year
Europe accounts for half the world's
tourist arrivals and is facing
staggering losses EU ministers are due
to hold a virtual summit later today to
discuss how they can help an industry in
crisis from Paris to Brussels European
capitals that should be filled with
people lie almost empty and silent with
borders closed and members of the public
forced to stay home Europe's tourism
industry is in dire straits the European
market accounts for half of world
tourism according to the EU Commission
it fears the tourism economy within the
20:7 nation bloc could fall by up to 70
percent that could result in the loss of
up to 400 billion euros for the industry
Spain is the most popular tourist
destination in the EU it's also the
world's second most visited nation but
there are no visitors these days for bar
owners like Pablo Gonzalo it's a
worrying time serpent daily year 2020 is
practically blank many businesses will
not reopen because they won't be able to
continue right now the only thing to do
is to look month by month and not think
about the distant horizon across the
border the Portuguese government has
said it will start reopening hotels in
June for those that are still in
business others are taking things into
their own hands in Berlin hotel and
restaurant owners have taken empty
chairs to Brandenburg Gate to illustrate
just how tough life has become for them
bollène leap from to his mother Lin
lives on tourism if we don't support our
hotels and restaurants with this action
who will most European governments are
already offering more financial support
to tourism and travel sectors but for
some businesses it may already be too
late all for the very latest let's cross
over to DW correspondent Bant liga in
brussels bet we heard about Spain in
that story what other countries in
Europe are hurting from the collapse of
tourism and travel yet when they think
of tourism in Europe of course all
southern countries come to mind Italy
Portugal Greece even Cyprus they make a
lot of revenue out of tourism in the
case of Spain 100 billion euros a year
but also other countries are suffering
for example Germany makes 260 billion
euros out of tourism every year so all
the European countries are affected more
dependent some are more dependent on the
revenue like Greece and so all EU
ministers try to come up with a plan how
to reopen the borders in Europe so that
people can can actually travel to other
countries but there are many concepts in
the air nobody knows exactly the
timetable Austria for example wants to
open up for its neighbors like Germany
Hungary or Slovenia the Spain also wants
to lure in tourists again as early as
June but the German Minister German
Foreign Minister Jaco Mars is warning
don't make it so quick he's talking or
thinking about the September well II
ministers are meeting today at a
distance to discuss solutions they'll
talk about ways of supporting the
tourism industry but there's little they
can do to bring the tourists back right
away on destination that's feeling the
pinch is hashed out in Austria the
residents who once complained about
being overrun by visitors there now find
themselves dealing with the opposite
extreme welcomed how start up
sure perfect gem in the Austrian Alps
before the pandemic in the village drew
a million tourists a year one tour bus
after the other day in day out and now
[Music]
everyone's gone no buses no tourists no
souvenir photos for many hallstatt was
something out of a fairy tale a bucket
list destination that thousands
documented on their Instagram accounts
[Music]
but while tourists admired the old
houses and filled the streets many
locals felt overwhelmed the problem is
that I almost never spend any time
outside anymore it's simply too loud out
here on my Terrace not anymore
now Hallstatt is a ghost town and the
locals aren't sure whether they like
that either
soul even sweats on to know it's such a
charming place and now we have it all to
ourselves again but even so we miss the
tourists from the weeks it's gone from
one extreme to the other
somewhere in the middle would be best
the situation isn't good for us either
kind of spooky in the village I take a
deep breath and that calms me down
somehow it's an unpleasant feeling just
now the residents of Hallstatt are
learning how much they miss the tourists
and the money they bring with them some
locals can't wait for the commotion to
return to the newly quiet streets of
their Alpine Idol so looking ahead what
could tourism in Europe look like once
it does come back to life the European
Union is trying to come up with some
guidelines how to reorganize travel that
concerns hotels short hotels only be
booked half so short they only serve one
course meals with the throw away cutlery
as things like that to keep sanitation
and to keep a health concept and there's
also the question
how do people actually travel will
Airlines be able to leave the middle
seat free will how will the airports be
organized all this has to be hammered
out but it's also clear that the common
approach is very difficult some
countries want to do it earlier some
countries want to do it later
and so the motor this year might be a
stay at home stay at your own nation so
Germans will vacation in Germany
Austin's will vacation in in Austria
this is the most likely scenario and the
u.s. borning that the travel industry
will only come back to its normal level
next year and thank you very much GWS
bands Leggett in Brussels the Spanish
government is debating which areas of
life can be eased out of lockdown and
when Spain's been severely hit by the
pandemic and madrid wants hotels bars
and restaurants to stay closed until the
end of the year but local politicians
and businesses are up in arms
many rely on tourism and want to reopen
in mid-july dwn Philip Schultz went to
the usually busy beach resort of
Marbella to see how people are planning
for a summer with the coronavirus a
vacation paradise in standby mode in
mid-march this pool in Marbella was
crowded with holidaymakers the hotel
almost at capacity says hotel director
Fernando elf ark until from one day to
the next
everything shut down now he just hopes
he can reopen the hotel in time for the
high season in July everything is ready
we could open tomorrow if we had two
weeks before we had to close we revised
all our hygiene procedures and so far
not a single guest or employee has
become infected with the corona virus
but so far there's no information on
what the Health Regulations for hotels
in Spain will be a growing number of
hotels expect the next high season to be
next year in economic disaster tourism
employs about two million people here in
Spain and
doesn't include the many small
businesses that depend on tourists some
Beach restaurants in Marbella are
offering delivery and takeout meals for
locals and retirees who came here for
the winter and couldn't or didn't want
to return home right now is a little bit
difficult but we are increasing the
sales everyday people know that we do
home delivery and take away so they my
bias business owners hope that at least
Spanish tourists hit the beaches this
summer the challenge will be making the
beaches safe for everyone two metres
distance between each beach towel that
would be about this much space between
each vacationer that's one of the many
plans being considered she and Spain at
the moment to at least partially safe
this year's beach season but many are
asking is this plan feasible and who
would end up enforcing these measures
some people are calling for a kind of
beach police one businessman from Italy
has designed plexiglass boxes that could
be set up to reduce contact between
sunbathers we talked to him via
videolink from his office in northern
Italy he told us he has had inquiries
from resorts all over Europe including
Spain we want to make this invention
even better for example we are working
on a spray system on the outside walls
to disinfect the area it's an idea that
Fernando el FARC cannot imagine for his
hotel he says he's getting bombarded
with curious inventions but what he
really needs is reliable information
from the government about what
regulations he'll have to meet and when
he can reopen his hotel